[Musique]
chéri on fera ça demain on devrait pas
plutôt aller se coucher vas-y toi je
dois finir la déco du dîner et
réorganiser le plan de table
d'accord
SALUT MAMAN c'est pas le moment tu dois
te le demander c'est héréditaire ou tu
fais beaucoup de j'ai hâte
[Musique]
on te fait un cadeau c'est ton objet
emprunté cette porte-bonheur sauf pour
l'oncle Greg quand il s'est fait
décapiter sur un chariot élévateur mais
c'était pas la faute du couteau
je viens de le trouver dans les
toilettes madame
t'as invité ton ex porno
[Musique]
tu es tellement plus belle que nous tous
je crois que ton nichons gauche est
légèrement plus bas que le droit
il y a un truc qui va pas
[Applaudissements]
tout le monde en otage
je le piège dans la moustiquaire
[Musique]
pas une seule fois je me suis dit que je
me baladerai menotté à travers la jungle
avec une vraie Grenade
[Musique]
vous êtes mort on va tout arranger
ça va plus jamais c'est trop mal je
voulais un truc moins traditionnel
personne non merde ma famille
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
Carole merci pour le couteau à gâteaux
plus beau cadeau